Нова митниця України позиціонує себе
сучасною структурою з кардинально новими
підходами в роботі. Вантажі на 7 пунктах пропуску
вже перевіряють не люди, а машини.
Це як перевірка валіз в аеропорту: задекларовано
вантаж із металевими виробами, а сканер показав
щось інше - машину зупиняють і починають розбиратися.
- Щоб оглянути транспортний засіб,
ми його заганяємо на поглиблений огляд,
і розвантажити цей транспортний засіб у нас займає
2, 3, 4 години, а то й добу.
За допомогою цього обладнання ми можемо
зробити це за 15 хвилин.
Такі сканери Україна закупила в Китаю вже давно,
але тривалий час вони просто припадали пилом на складах ДФС.
Новому голові Держмитслужби Максиму Нефьодову
коштувало багатьох зусиль витягти їх звідти
та запустити в дію. І це лише одна з перших
серйозних змін на новій митниці для реальної
боротьби з контрабандою.
Новий голова пообіцяв митниці "нове життя"
і "кардинальні зміни". Його попередники також
щедро роздавали такі обіцянки, але контрабанда
лише розквітала. Утім, Максим Нефьодов запевняє,
що має особливий підхід.
- Наша мета
полягає не стільки в тому, що усіх спіймаємо,
всіх оштрафуємо чи посадимо.
Наша мета - це зробити так, аби возити контрабанду
було невигідно. Зрозуміло чисто математично, що
якщо ми будемо знаходити навіть кожен сьомий
чи восьмий подібний вантаж,
це економіку контрабанди вб’є.
Нова митниця ініціює більш тісну співпрацю
з правоохоронними органами. Зокрема, створення
єдиної бази даних, аби правоохоронці й митники
могли оперативно ділитися інформацією
про підозрілі вантажі або відстежувати вже затримані.
Також останніми місяцями митники,
прикордонники та співробітники СБУ спільно
провели серію обшуків на великих ринках України.
Виявили десятки тонн товарів на сотні мільйонів гривень,
які були провезені через кордон без сплати мит та податків,
а це величезні суми, які могли поповнити бюджет.
- Візьмемо ринок автозапчастин.
Ми почали переводити оцінку вартості товарів,
з кілограмів почали міряти в штуках.
Раптом виявилося, що бюджет почав заробляти
на цій категорії 70-80 млн гривень більше на місяць.
Насправді це круто.
Нова митниця декларує, що хоче зробити все,
аби водіям було комфортно перетинати
український кордон. Однак самі водії
за півроку реформи цього не відчули,
і навіть сканери їх не втішають.
- Раніше ми стояли 50 годин,
тепер будемо стояти 100 годин.
(говорять одночасно)
- Зі сканером у десять разів довше.
Водії розлючені. Більшість із них напередодні
різдвяних свят провела в чергах
на польсько-українському кордоні кілька діб.
-  20 років ми тут їздимо, і 20 років тут от такий балаган. Ніколи тут не було порядку.
- Дивіться, скільки вікон тут працює. А скільки народу стоїть і чекає?
На 2020 рік заплановане розширення пунктів пропуску.
Мають реконструювати 16 пунктів пропуску,
які будувалися ще в часи, коли не було "безвізу"
з ЄС, тому ці митні пости не були розраховані
на таку велику кількість людей та машин.
- Якщо ви хочете побачити реформу митниці, поїдьте, будь ласка,
на німецько-швейцарський кордон. Подивіться, як там працюють.
15-30 хвилин - і машини поїхали.
- Хай об’єднують цю границю з поляками разом.
Хай спрощують. Що це таке?
Скільки це буде тягнутися? Хай розширяють.
Що, додатково людей немає? Комп’ютерів немає?
Працівники митниці також втомилися від постійних
скандалів із водіями. Через застарілу техніку
багато часу витрачається на набирання
на комп’ютері даних паспортів громадян та їхніх машин.
Анна Шаткова хотіла б працювати в інших умовах
і має великі надії, що реформа митниці дійде
і до її робочого місця.
- Наше програмне забезпечення трохи застаріло.
Навіть не трохи. Зараз
по всьому світу йде розвиток IT.
Ті самі банки: ми можемо вдома на дивані
зробити все, що потрібно, не виходячи з кімнати.
Думаю, що наша електрона митниця теж буде прогресувати.
Митниця у смартфоні - не така вже й далека реальність.
Оформлення документів на машини та вантажі
хочуть повністю перевести в онлайн
до кінця 2020 року. Також у планах -
єдине декларування вантажів із ЄС, зокрема
транзитних. Об’єднання баз даних має розпочатися
теж у 2020-му.
- Електроні права з телефонів, розрахунок на касі
в супермаркеті з телефонів. А чому не може водій
з телефона образно занести інформацію в базу?
Розумієте, про що ми говоримо?
Ми говоримо про завтрашній день.
Але на сьогоднішній день ми залишилися…
Ви бачили, в якому стані приміщення.
Десь сморід, десь негарне повітря,
десь хлорка в туалеті. Ну, воно є таке.
Оновлення кадрів, що триває в Держмитслужбі
вже пів року, має сприяти реалізації амбітних планів,
які декларує новий голова Держмитслужби Максим Нефьодов.
Працівникам митниці хочуть підвищити зарплатню
мінімум удвічі, аби ті виконували свою роботу добросовісно.
- Звичайно, важко очікувати, що
зміна керівництва митниці якимсь магічним способом
має призвести до того, що в нас на завтра з’явилися
нові  пункти пропуску, немає черг і всі митники
стали ввічливими й доброчесними.
Звичайно, я розумію бажання людей мати результат
швидше, і вони мають право це вимагати.
Моє завдання - максимально  активно працювати,
аби ті зміни втілювати в життя.
Нова митниця мала пів року на підготовку реформи.
Із 9 грудня вона офіційно запрацювала.
Нефьодов упевнений: поволі запрягали - швидко поїдуть.